(soft music)
- That just like hit me right here.
- Mom, can you hear? I don't
want you to hear what it is.
- This is heavy. How heavy do you get?
- Ah, yeah, so the most
hurtful thing I've been told,
'cause I've thought
about this for a while,
it wasn't told to me,
it was written to me.
My mom sent me an email, she
sent an email to everybody.
So it doesn't feel like
it should hurt as much
if everybody got the
brunt end of the stick.
But she told all of us
that she no longer wants to be,
she no, sorry, I never shared like this.
She doesn't wanna be our mom anymore.
She's no longer anybody's mother,
she's no longer anybody's sister.
She's just decided not
to be anybody's family.
So actually, when I
have spoken about this,
I'm usually a lot stronger
explaining what happened.
So I don't know why I'm
crying at this point
when I don't usually cry when
I tell people about this.
So, you know, life has been
super good after she left.
I think it honestly brought
the family together,
a closer relationship, a
more deeper relationship
with my aunties and my
siblings and my stepdad.
And so it, there's like a
silver lining to all of it.
- Recently my ex-boyfriend
called me on the phone one day
when we were still together
and told me that he hated me
and that I was a low-value
woman because of my past,
because of things that I've done.
And I never thought I could
be hurt by such simple words.
It caused me to change my
identity so drastically.
I shaved my head.
My hair's just finally growing out.
From that hurt, I just
had to get away from it
and shed the person I was
and become someone different
because that one thing hurt me so bad.
I just like lost myself in that pain.
And I'm finally starting
to come out of that pain
and coming into myself and
feeling my strength again.
And I can still really feel
the hurt of those words.
- I would say it's not
necessarily what I've been told,
but more around the actions.
So like when I was younger,
I used to have the worst
allergies ever, right?
And so, and I was also left-handed,
so it was like almost like this
like awkward double whammy I was getting.
And you know, like when
you're in like grade school
you guys would sit in
like these little cubes?
And so like sometimes my elbow would
like end up brushing up
against my classmate and
or I would end up sneezing and
slowly yet surely over time
it was like my desk was an island
and the rest of the the little
pod that I was supposed to be
was maybe like another
five feet away from me.
In the moment, I hated
life. I will admit that.
But in retrospect, it was needed.
And 'cause at this point
like it's allowed me
to just be that much strong of a person
where it's like I know
that it's really not gonna
be that bad because this too shall pass.
I just need to keep pushing
my rock up the hill.
Sure it sucks today, but
eventually I picked my rock.
And for me, today, my
rock is playing guitar.
And so every day I'm
just playing more guitar,
trying to get better,
trying to find my sound.
And if you could find that,
honestly, what more could you ask for?
- The time that the gynecologist told me
that I lost my child.
I felt that literally like,
like if the cat was
ripping my heart out of me.
it was a disturbing feeling
that I never thought that I would felt.
And the most painful
thing about it is what?
That I was holding my dad's hand
and I saw my dad cry with
me for the first time.
- Probably I don't
deserve such a nice kid.
I have two kids and somebody
told me that I don't deserve.
They are too good for me to be a father
because I have a quite a background
sometimes was a little shaky,
but this was the most hurtful.
I felt sorry for this
person who said that.
Why would you say something like this?
You know, it's like you have
to be very, very angry inside
to say something like this.
- [Interviewer] Do you still
carry that hurt with you?
Like does it still?
- No, no, no.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- No, no, I don't.
Because it would destroy my peace of mind
and it would've destroyed me from inside.
- Repeat the question.
- [Interviewer] What's the most painful,
hurtful thing you've been told?
- All right, so I'm gonna share this
just because I think that I wanna,
I want people to love themselves
despite what they may have been told
that could have made them hate themselves.
I was told by my mother that
I should not have been born.
She repeated that to me
throughout my whole life.
I don't remember how old I was
when she first told me that
she should have aborted me.
I love my life so much
that I don't understand
how anybody else could not love me.
But I also don't know if it's
because she doesn't love me
or because she didn't want to be a mother.
I don't think it's the truth talking,
I think it's just her pain.
And I've never said it
like this out loud before.
So no one has ever asked me this question.
- It would be a while
back, like 10 years ago.
It was actually my first girlfriend ever.
We were outside my house and she had said,
"You're not enough for me."
And that kind of, kind of
hurt, you know, broke me.
I was like, what? Like 15, 16.
And she told me that,
just completely broke me.
Not gonna lie, every once
in a while, I'm in my bed,
thinking about, hurts again.
Makes me think maybe I'm
still not enough for someone.
- [Interviewer] Have you
had a relationship since?
- I have not, no.
I just gotta learn to love myself
before I could love others.
But I'll think about it.
- The thing at this time
that's coming to mind
is a time when I was a
freshman in high school.
I was, there was, my high school
was about 45 minutes away.
And so I was in the car with a bunch
of other boys from where I lived
and I was picked on a lot
'cause I was a lot smaller,
all the other kids knew each other.
I was the new kid. I was always
forced inside the middle.
You know, they played punching games.
Anyways, at the end of the car ride
I was crying this one time,
and one of the other guys
who I thought was like,
you know, my friend said,
"Hey, I'm really sorry, like, you know,
like I promise, like I
won't do that again."
Two days later, he was
up to the same thing
and it really just, I don't
know, struck me really hard.
And so yeah, you know,
that was a very tough time in my life and,
but I look back on that time,
being able to experience stuff
like that and overcome it,
it teaches a lot of
resilience within a person.
In adult life, you need
a lot of resilience,
you know, to really make
a impact on this world.
And I feel like that's
something I really wanna do.
- Oh God, I feel like I do know.
It's like not even something
somebody said to me,.
People just like,
there's been a few people
who've asked like what's wrong with me?
And like if I'm on drugs before.
There was like one
specific time at a party,
somebody was like, "What are you on?"
And like would not give it up.
They just would not stop asking.
Like I was drinking
'cause it was like a party
but like barely.
And I just was like being normal
and they were like, "What are you on?
Like no, tell me. Like seriously."
And I was just like,
"I'm just, just normal.
Just like being myself."
I don't know, really makes
makes you feel like an outcast
when people literally ask
like what's wrong with you
and when you think you're just normal.
I think it's also like what
people like about me too.
So it's like I've learned to
like love that about myself
and not like hate myself for it,
which has been very like
good for me I guess, yeah.
- My dad has told me he's
really disappointed in me
when I was really young.
And that kind of hurt, you know,
hearing that you disappointed your father
at 14 kind of hurts.
He just looked me up and down and said,
"I'm really disappointed in you."
And I just went back
inside and I went to bed
'cause that was kind of rough for me.
- Ah, most hurtful thing.
I do remember very vividly
when I was probably about 14 or 15,
walking home from school one day
and running into a
girlfriend and her boyfriend
as I, as we walked by, he
stopped to talk to me, you know?
And I kind of thought, "Oh, you
know, I'm being acknowledged
or something, like kind of a big deal."
But then he said,
"Just wanted to know,
how did you get so ugly?"
And it was just something that did
actually stick with me over the years.
It was defining in a way that it made me,
you know, it sort of contributed who I am.
I've always been sort of one
to make a little bit of extra effort,
although you can't tell
now but I'm like old.
But that's just what popped into my head.
- I was a kid boarding school.
I was in the seventh grade.
The seventh grade teacher
was the principal.
And we were in class and he said to me,
"Michael, there's no
conceit in your family."
And I'm going, "Oh, whoa."
He says, "You've got it all."
I didn't know I was conceited.
He told me I was.
And so that's when I started
questioning that part of me.
I was still developing and
I was in a boarding school
and I had a bad, my background
was tumultuous, to say the least.
When I was five years old,
my mother's second husband molested me.
I blurted it out to my uncle that,
what my father made me do.
They called my mother.
My mother divorced him.
Several years later,
she married another man,
he molested me. I was in the third grade.
And so that's when I got
taken out of my family
or away from my mother,
and put in boarding school
because my grandmother
knew that was going down
and she didn't know it.
My mother was an alcoholic,
her husbands were alcoholics.
She was indifferent to me, generally.
I was the product of her first marriage
being dragged along in her second marriage
and her third marriage.
And I don't think she was happy
because I was the cause of the breakup
of her second marriage.
And I think she really
was in love with this guy.
She had three kids by him.
After I revealed what he was
doing and they got divorced,
I think that really turned
her off to me in general.
Like, "I just don't like this kid."
So boarding school was
a good place for me.
I went into boarding school,
came out of boarding school,
went to high school for one year.
So I joined the Navy.
After 10 years, and here's
another moment, I'm gay.
In the 10th year of my
enlistment, I got outed
and the Office of Naval Intelligence,
ONI, came after me, threatened me
and I didn't want to
get kicked out, but I.
They had me, I couldn't
reenlist, so I just said,
"Okay, you won't see me around
when my enlistment is up in three months."
And I did my GED, I got out,
got my bachelor's degree in nursing
and then about 10 years ago, I retired.
So I am now an RN. Registered
nurse? No, retired nurse.
- [Interviewer] You've been through a lot.
How were you able to like push through it?
- I don't know, you know,
I've often asked myself that question.
I was a, I was running scared,
but I was determined not to fall.
See, I've got a lot of
blessings in my life.
I'm 82 years old.
I have no medical problems.
I have no financial problems.
Which is all just to say,
what a awesome life I live, you know?
- I think the most painful
thing I was ever told
was when I was five years old,
my aunt pulled me aside
and she told me I was never
going to amount to anything,
that I was going to be a hoe.
I was gonna have multiple
men. I was gonna be a failure.
I wasn't gonna do anything
that meant anything.
And that really stuck with me
for a really, really long time.
I think it was part of the reason
why I try so hard to make change now,
because I'm trying to prove her wrong.
I don't hate anyone, but, she, she,
I'm like this close to hating this woman.
But I also feel like I
kind of want to thank her
for being so evil, because
now I only see the world
with kindness and I try to make sure
like I exemplify that in
everything in my life.
And I feel like with time,
I've like developed myself
and I'm able to finally like
give people that kindness
that I wish I had when I was five, so.
(soft music)
- Hi, everyone.
I know I've been gone for
a while, but I'm back.
And I just wanna say thank
you for watching this episode.
I love you all and I'll see you next time.
(soft music)